OPERATION IN 2016.
CONSPIRACY THEORY THAT THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL HAS EMBRACED.
>> NOTICED HOW POLITICIANS AND
JOURNALISTS USE THE EXACT SAME
TALKING POINT.
CONGRESSMAN DEVIN NUNES NOTICED
THAT, HEART OF THE RUSSIA PROBE
AT THE VERY BEGINNING.
WHAT WASHINGTON DID TO REVERSE
THE 2016 ELECTION.
THAT STORY IN A NEW BOOK, THE
PLOT AGAINST THE PRESIDENT IN
THE TRUE STORY OF CONGRESSMAN
DEVIN NUNES UNCOVERING THE
BIGGEST SCANDAL IN AMERICAN
HISTORY, NUMBER ONE IN THE
AMAZON LIST.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING ON.
>> THANK YOU.
VERY KIND, BUT THERE'S A LOT OF
PEOPLE WE DID A LOT OF GREAT
WORK.
>> I'M GOING TO READ IT.
TELL ME WHAT YOU MAKE OF
JOURNALISTS IN WASHINGTON
DEMANDING THAT WE STOP ASKING
QUESTIONS?
OUR DEFAULT IS WE ALWAYS WANT TO
KNOW MORE.
THAT'S OUR JOB.
YET THEY ARE TELLING US, NO MORE
QUESTIONS!
WHY ARE THEY TELLING US THAT?
>> MORE THAN THAT, IT'S EVEN
WORSE.
YOU HAVE ALL THE CONSPIRACY
THEORIES, THEY ARE CHASING DAILY
CONSPIRACY THEORIES ON THESE
UKRAINE HOOKS.
WHAT I'VE BEEN TRYING TO TELL MY
COLLEAGUES, IF THESE ARE
MAINSTREAM REPORTERS AND THEY
ARE OUT THERE ASKING YOU
QUESTIONS ABOUT CONSPIRACY
THEORIES ABOUT TRUMP AND WHAT DO
YOU THINK ABOUT -- DID YOU SEND
ANYBODY TO THIS PLACE QUICK TO
MAKE EVERY DAY IS A NEW
CONSPIRACY THEORY.
WHEN I WALKED ON THE HALL, I'M
NOT GOING TO TELL YOU IN THIS
LIFETIME OR THE NEXT, THEY
AREN'T REAL REPORTERS.
THEY ARE ASSASSINS, THEY ARE
SPREADING IT OUT THERE.
>> Tucker: THEY ARE DNC
OPERATIVES.
>> Sean:
>> WE NEED A FREE AND FAIR
PRESS.
THAT'S NOT WE HAVE TODAY.
>> Tucker: I DON'T KNOW.
WE AREN'T RUSHING TO REFLECT --
I DON'T WORK FOR TRUMP.
THESE PEOPLE WORKED ON THE
DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY.
THEY ARE HACKS.
WHAT DO WE KNOW ON THIS LATE
DATE WHAT EXACTLY HAPPENED.
WHY DID NOT WE SEE MANY
EXAMPLES, THE FULL-SIZE
APPLICATIONS
THE FULLFISA APPLICATIONS.
>> HORWITZ IS GATHERING ALL
THE -- HE SAID LAST FRIDAY, I
BELIEVE, IT'S GOING TO HAVE VERY
FEW REACTIONS.
THAT WOULD TELL ME WE ARE GOING
TO GET TO SEE A LOT OF THAT
FISA.
WHEN YOU GO TO THE BROADER
INVESTIGATION, WHY DID MUELLER
SPEND $35 MILLION AND NOT GET TO
THE BOTTOM OF WHAT ACTUALLY
HAPPENED, AND I THINK THIS NEEDS
TO HAPPEN.
THERE ARE INVESTIGATORS AND
LAWYERS THAT WERE ON THE STEELE
THAT ALSO HAVE TO BE LOOKED AT.
BECAUSE IF THEY DIDN'T GET TO
THE SOME OF THE STUFF THAT
HORWITZ IS GOING TO GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF, WE HAVE A LOT TO BE
CONCERNED ABOUT.
JUST TODAY, IN OTHER BREAKING
NEWS, THERE'S ALWAYS BREAKING
NEWS EVERY SINGLE DAY ON THE
SUBJECT, BUT GENERAL FLYNN WHO
WAS MALIGNED, AND LEE TALKS
ABOUT IN HIS BOOK THE MONKEY WAS
MALIGNED BACK IN 2014, THE
MALIGNED AND IN 2016, HAD THIS
RUSSIAN GIRLFRIEND, ALL
NONSENSE.
FINALLY TODAY A JUDGE CANCELED
THE FLYNN HEARING.
I HOPE THE JUDGE WILL READ --
THE JUDGE WILL THROW THIS OUT.
THIS IS NOT A WAY TO TREAT A WAR
HERO.
>> Tucker: OF COURSE NOT.
MEANWHILE, HE'S NOT THE ONLY
ONE.
NEXT WEEK, ROGER STONE GOING ON
TRIAL AND LIKELY GOING TO SPEND
THE REST OF HIS LIFE IN PRISON.
>> THAT'S QUESTIONABLE.